Try by day Joe Rogan podcast by night all day.
That's a weird thing to see someone have that.
Cause there's a,
there's an amazing like confidence that you have to have a or like,
uh,
at least you have to get yourself to that place.
And it took like,
you know,
compete in MMA like you said,
without looking at the side of the road.
And when you see that broken,
I mean when I saw that,
uh,
that Ellen interview with Rhonda Rousey,
Yeah.
That was so crazy to me.
That really made me go like maybe she shouldn't fight for a little while.
Like I dunno,
I like,
she needs some more time off because this,
she went from being the like,
I'm going to kill everyone.
No one has a right to beat me.
Don't be a B,
nothing bitch.
And being that chick to being like a,
I wanted to kill myself.
I got to just have Travis Brown's babies and I was like,
Whoa,
she's gone from being this like untouchable.
I mean,
not even like she was like the best female fighter.
It was like,
don't even,
she's wrecking chicks in a second and then to seeing her kind of broken,
well,
it's interesting is these themed play themselves out over and over again.
And the traps are all there,
but everybody keeps going for the candy and they keep getting caught in the
traps.
The traps of Hollywood are always there for any superstar athlete,
especially fighters.
And you know,
we've seen it all throughout history with Tommy Morrison gets in the rocky movie
and all of a sudden everybody's looking at him like Tommy Marson is going to be
the white hub.
And then Ray Mercer beats the living fuck out of them.
And you just saw like fear and overwhelming anxiety attack him.
Cause he's in this movie and he's on the red carpet and everybody's saying,
you're going to be the champ one day.
Huh?
I was like,
Oh fuck.
And then it becomes this whole thing.
He's hanging with Sylvester Stallone.
They're probably doing blow and bang and hookers and allegedly allegedly.
But you know what I mean?
It's like it becomes this Hollywood trap.
And Rhonda was a g and still is a giant superstar,
right?
She's this undefeated women's fighter.
She's crushing all the competition.
She looks like a destroyer.
And then the fucking traps this,
all these movies started coming out,
all this,
all these deals start getting made.
Books start getting written.
All these television shows and all this stuff and all the traps and all those
traps,
they keep your focus.
They take steal little bits of your focus.
Like I'm good enough to get by without all that focus.
But there's no way,
because there's another person like you out there,
there's,
there's a lot of people like you out there and they don't have those traps.
And if they don't have those traps are going to have more attention that's being
paid right away.
They had an advantage because they have their full focused on this.
And then there's also something dangerous to someone like Ron Torres.
But by the way,
obviously it's just incredible.
I mean,
she's the reason why women's MMA is a huge thing.
Uh,
but I think there's something dangerous about being such an amazing grappler,
getting a couple knockouts and all of a sudden feeling this kind of like,
oh yeah,
you know,
she got the knee to a McMahon and stops it with one knee.
And then what was the other chick who she,
she hit the overhand who face planted Alexis Davis.
Yeah.
And so now it's kind of going in there and even going in there with like a world
class,
a boxer,
like a Holly Holm,
she kind of goes in there with like,
well,
I can knock people out.
And I think that's a dangerous,
you know,
all,
you know what is a dangerous combination being a blue belt and you chuck got a
bunch of white belts and you think you're the shit,
and then all of a sudden you're rolling with Damien Maia and he wraps you up
like a Christmas present.
Beats the fuck out of you and chokes you.
Unconscious Z,
you know?
I mean,
there's levels of everything.
And to deny those levels because anybody who looked at her fights would see
like,
okay,
you have this Rhonda Rousey.
This fierce competitor was one of the best judo examples of judo.
We've ever seen an MMA.
I mean her judo spectacular reason why she was a medalist in the Olympics.
I mean,
she's a sensational competitor.
Her grappling is outstanding.
Her arm bar technique is amongst the best in the world,
but she's knocking out these girls there.
There's no,
they're nowhere near Worldclass as far as like kickboxing is striking is
concerned.
Right.
Holly Holm is 100% worldclass.
She is an 18 time world boxing champion.
I mean,
she's a kickboxing champion.
She was in a an MMA competitor for a couple of years before she got into the UFC
where she was having these ridiculous head kick.
Kaos yeah,
she's a beast and for her to think that she's going to treat this woman,
this Holly Holm woman,
the same way she was able to bully like Batchko Heyah and I say Billy,
not in a negative way.
I mean just just attacker and go after [inaudible] hey,
I was,
she's slow and awkward and not that athletic.
Holly Holm bounces around that cage like a fucking kangaroo.
Yeah.
She does all these back flips and shit.
She's spectacular.
The athletic and the idea that you're going to have the same approach they used
on Batchko go,
hey,
with someone like Holly Holm,
that's just madness.
And that's something that happens when people get so absorbed with this idea
that they're special.
So absorbed with this idea that,
you know,
when you're on top,
you think you are the fucking person.
You're the woman,
you're the man,
you're the shit.
No one's going to fuck with you.
I'm just wandering through this bitch.
Yeah.
And then you get cracked and then you realize,
oh,
this game doesn't give a fuck.
This game doesn't give a fuck about your charisma.
It doesn't give a fuck about the Vegas odds.
It doesn't give a fuck about how much money you made or how many times you've
been on entourage.
That's the amazing,
it's an amazing thing about MMA.
It's why I have so much respect for everybody who competes.
But it's like no one can escape this game's wrath.
No,
I mean like John Jones still has a lot of his career to go and he does,
he has one loss on his record,
but it was not dominant,
you know,
when,
uh,
but you know,
you see these guys,
like you see Anderson Silva and he's just like,
he's a Ninja.
He's untouchable.
He's the greatest fighter ever.
And then you see him like crying on the ground with a shattered,
not shattered,
but whatever.
When he broke his shin.
Well,
how about when cried in the ground after he won against Nick Diaz?
He fell to the ground cried ever.
By the way,
Nick Dsi just,
it's pretty awesome.
I mean,
the Diaz brothers are just the greatest fighters of all time.
They certainly are.
Um,
yeah.
But yeah,
well,
from going full circle then when he comes back and wins in the octagon.
But I mean,
it's,
it's an incredible thing.
It makes you look,
I mean,
when watching chuck owl who I just,
you know,
at a certain point you were like,
that guy's just unbeatable.
He's like Superman.
And then to see him get knocked out and kind of his chin,
you know,
slowly start to go,
yeah,
it's,
it's like this,
this game,
this game doesn't give a fuck,
doesn't give a fuck about your opinions.
Doesn't give a fuck about what you think when knuckles hit Chin's legs go limp.
And that's just how it goes.
And we saw that in the Rockhold Bisping fight,
you know,
Rockhold had this look about him that almost like he was bored,
that he was just like,
I'm going to go.
I mean,
part of that I'm sure as gamesmanship,
he's trying to get inside Bisping's head that he's so much better than him,
that he doesn't even have to be serious and be concerned.
And then Bisbing clips him with his left hook over the shoulder where he's
barely seen it.
I said,
you called it,
it was a great cause what you said,
like a few beats before that we were like,
Luke Rockhold keeping his chin right on up in the air and he's kind of like a
little lacks of days ago.
Yeah,
I remember you,
uh,
in the,
um,
in the Hennen Borow Dillashaw fight.
The first one was like a huge upset.
No one saw that coming.
Uh,
and I remember you,
you sang as it was,
you're like,
man,
Dillashaw is really light on his feet too much.
I was really relaxed.
Like sometimes you could just see a little thing in the way they're moving.
They were like,
hmm.
That's kind of interesting.
Yeah.
I was telling you before we started recording my,
my buddy hilarious comedian,
one of my best friends,
Lewis j Gomez,
he does a radio show with Michael Bisbing and uh,
you've had a big J.
I'm going gonna show the three of us do a podcast and a legion of skanks.
You,
you got to have Lewis on.
You'll fucking,
I would love to,
he's like Jay.
Yeah,
Jay.
Jay's a,
I've got a special coming out,
which is going to be just incredible.
It's it on comedy central hour.
Oh,
cool.
I'll coming out on,
I believe,
I want to say June 17th,
but I might,
it's like one of those days,
it's called a live at Webster hall.
It's going to be a fucking incredible special look for that.
Jay is like one of the funniest comedians on the planet.
Very funny.
Louis J.
Gomez is just one of the funniest people I've ever met in my life.
He's a great comedian.
He's like bigger than a standup comedian.
He's like the Bert Kreischer of the east coast.
He's just a hilarious person.
Uh,
but so he's doing a show with Michael Bisbing.
They do a show called the countdown on Sirius Radio and he started doing the
show.
I mean this is before Bisbing has the Anderson Silva fight and it did almost
seem kind of like Brisbane was a great fighter,
a big name,
but seemed like he was kind of going toward the end of his career.
Like it had a couple injuries,
had the eye thing and you're kinda like,
oh he was,
he was a contender.
Well explain the,
I think cause the,
I think is pretty bad.
Yeah.
You probably know better than he has a detached retina and he has oil in his
eye.
They had to inject oil into where his,
I sit so that his retina won't tear again.
So he has one eye that looks almost like cross side and it's kind of black like
is like he's on ecstasy,
like one pupils dilated.
It's very weird and he doesn't give a fuck.
He's got that one I fucked up and he doesn't give a shit.
He's still going in there and soloing and then is born for this.
This,
this mother fucker went out and fought Anderson Silva won one of the gutsiest
performances I've ever,
and I mean he,
the,
the first two rounds that he beat Anderson were just incredible.
And then the fact that he got almost put out in the third round and came back
and won the fourth round and it was a fucked up for him because he was trying to
say that his mouthpiece was out and he tried to circle to,
I don't know who the referee was.
I think it was herb.
Yeah.
And he's like,
but Herb's like,
look,
it doesn't matter.
Like you got to,
I'm not stopping that.
You don't,
you can't call when to stop the action.
Cause you could say that the mouthpieces out or you could just spit your
mouthpiece that whenever someone's,
you know,
like landed a big show,
people do time and people do do that.
But you know,
herb was like,
look,
you can't say to me that your mouthpiece out,
I know your mouth pieces out but you've got to keep fighting.
Then boom,
Anderson lands off flying me on the jot and then Anderson walks away with his
hands up.
It's so crazy as if he won so crazy.
Herb didn't call the fight yet.
So then the bell rings.
So then Bisping has to get up and recover in a minute from getting k Oud.
It was madness.
He got a little bit of extra time because Anderson Silva celebrated.
Yes.
So I think he got like an extra 30 seconds or so.
But I mean,
but then right.
So,
and by the way,
that's got to fuck Anderson up to cause Anderson's,
now I've got this like adrenaline dump and then he's,
and then you saw on his face,
he's like,
Whoa,
no,
we're back to fighting it.
But Bisbing man,
that fourth round,
he just bit down on his mouthpiece and walked him down.
And yeah,
I mean it was incredible.
Crazy.
And then after that being the greatest ever to come and,
and you get on a,
on an injury,
you get a title shot with 10 days' notice.
He fights the greatest ever.
I mean,
arguably Anderson's on the downslide but definitely,
let's not say arguably,
I mean losing twice to Weidman and it just didn't look the same when he fought
Nick Diaz suspended for steroids,
comes back and you know,
but he's still Anderson Silva.
So that victory gets that victory over the greatest of all time.
And then first round knockout over Luke Rockhold,
you know,
it's fucked up.
I was,
I was literally considering saying that Luke Rockhold looks overconfident and
when you're overconfident you can get knocked out.
And I'm like,
I don't want to be a deck.
And then boom,
he gets knocked out.
But you did make the comment about him holding a,
about him not having his head right there on the center line of sort of relaxed.
It was super relaxed with his chin straight up.
He was pulling out of things with his chin straight up.
It's almost like there was no danger.
Yeah.
And that was one of the things that he was saying that,
you know,
he was in no danger.
And it was also one of the same things that your Riaa Faber was saying.
Like the difference between me and cruises,
I can hurt him,
I can take him out.
And then when you see your riot got caught,
I think it was a second round,
he got dropped and you realize he's in deep trouble.
Like you realize,
Holy Shit,
I can get knocked out too.
And all those guys in,
you know,
it's,
it's uh,
it's funny when you get it,
like Michael Bisman is a guy who,
the knock on him,
I guess was that he didn't have knockout power or whatever.
You're talking about like a a 200 I mean fighting at two oh five I got it cuts
down probably,
I'm sorry,
one 85 so probably something someone who weighs close to 200 pounds.
It's a 200 pound guy who specializes in,
in striking.
Yeah.
I mean he can fucking knock you out of course.
And he proved it.
He doesn't,
he doesn't fight like a,
like a brawler like he fights like a technician and when you fight like a
technician,
you don't swing wild crazy ass punches with everything on them with your,
you know,
Vandelay Silva style,
you try to find openings and that's what he did.
He found the opening with that left hook was really sneaky.
He had missed it before.
He was like stepping in and throwing the left took over the shoulder and kind of
like stepping into the punch.
And boy when he caught Luke,
he caught him at the end of the chin,
which really like fucking spins your head.
All the Torque is perfectly placed.
And then he caught him with another brilliant one right afterwards.
Followed up.
Yeah man.
Dude.
And you know,
he's had like all sorts of fucking crazy injuries.
Back injuries,
neck injuries is fucking army.
Yeah,
he's just tough man.
He just keeps going.
It just keeps going.
She has no question about that.
That dude's as tough as they come in.
I don't know.
I've never fixed him just because he's one of those guys who's like been around
forever and always kind of been knocking at the door.
So it's nice to see him,
you know,
get his moment was crazy to see.
Well you see like there's knockout power,
right?
And then there's like Dan Henderson kind of knock out power that was just like,
she's fucking cry.
Like 10 Anderson feels like this table when you put your arm on him,
he's not flexing.
He's like the,
like Ryan Parsons,
who's a buddy of mine,
who was his manager for a long time,
said that he would do massage on him and he would be exhausted.
He's like,
he's would you guys made out of wood?
So like when you look at him,
you'll get him,
he go,
well it looks like a,
you know,
strong athletic guy.
But if you felt him,
you realize where all this power comes from.
He's like,
he's built different,
there's something going on with him and he does.
When you were saying people who don't put everything into one punch,
he puts everything into it.
I mean it's like coming at Ya and it's so weird the way he moves to moves in a
weird way because he's very stiff.
He's not fluid like John Jones or like Anderson is very fluid in his movements.
Dan is like very stiff,
but when he uncorked those bombs on you,
they just detonate and you're just like,
what the fuck hit me?
Like heck.
The lombards never been knocked out to see Hector Lombard get knocked out by,
well he got head kicked.
He's probably stunned by that head kick and then he got blasted with that back
elbow and he was out cold.
He was out cold when he hit the ground and then Henderson blast them again.
But like,
Whoa,
I saw,
I was like,
who the fuck hits?
Like this guy is like,
it's almost like you want him to hit you.
It just so he could feel it
harder.
Is that the normal like what it,
what the fuck are you doing?
I want to start by like standing next to a guy who he had hit him real close to
me.
I want to feel it.
His Kale,
if Bisping UFC 100 was one of the most brutal one punch shots and the history of
combat sports,
it was just boom Bisping's dead stiff,
and then Henderson's airborne long before the referee can get to them and just
slams him in the face on the way down.
And then from there out,
one of his logos was the silhouette of him flying through the air and knocking
out Bisping.
So imagine being best bang.
Not only do you have to deal with the fact this guy fucking knocked you out in
spectacular fashion,
but his logo is flying to the air,
hitting you after you're already unconscious.
I would,
I would just say,
hang on.
In a few years you'll be champ and you'll have a show with Lewis Jake Omens and
everything will be good.
What year was UFC 100 it's a wild man.
That was Brock Lesnar.
I want 100 yeah,
100 yeah.
100 was like,
was it 2012 no,
earlier than that,
probably.
What year was that Jamie?
I just pulled something up.
It wasn't UFC one 14 popped up.
It wasn't definitely,
wasn't that right?
It was UFC 100 yeah.
Let me see.
Okay.
It was the biggest paper view of all time was Brock Lesnar's rematch with Frank
Mir GSP photo Tiago album 2009 2009 wow.
It was that long ago.
Whoa.
That's nuts.
Yeah,
that was fucking weird.
It's been a long fucking longer than I would've thought.
Yeah,
definitely.
I guess it is like a hundred UFC is later.
Yeah.
Wow.
So seven years later he wins a title.
Crazy.
You're a look.
There's going to be the same,
same card on the same card,
right.
You guys,
look,
there's gonna be some ups and downs.
Your retina is going to get all types of fucked up,
but you will be champion one day and no one takes that away from him ever.
Could you imagine if him and Henderson had a rematch for the title?
Good Lord.
Can that be made?
I wonder if that could be made ethically,
because if you look at all the other contenders,
all the people waiting in line,
Chris,
while you're in Morocco,
Jacques Perrey Vittorio,
there's just too many.
Yeah,
there's too many,
but two who,
boy,
it's hard.
It's a hard sell because Vito or just knocked out Henderson the first round,
you know it's handy.
Yeah.
It's just man vitro knocked out Bisbing and Brazil and here knocked out Rockhold
but he just got smashed by Jacques Perrey.
Everything in the middleweight division is just completely up in the air and
it's all,
it's all turned up to that.
So weird in MMA,
will it happen?
Like you're kind of like,
oh,
okay,
I think I know where everything's sounds,
and then one thing changes and I'm like,
well,
I don't know anything.
I guess.